did you watch please tell me you watched
squid game
i haven't man i wanted to i know
i know i know i know i know good
i'm going to watch it i know what it's
about
yeah i know i vaguely know the premise
don't spoil do not spoil yeah so that
[ __ ] rocketed up to number one
yeah like the day it came out that's
awesome
yeah i don't want to talk
i don't want to talk about anything
that's you know
number one other than addison ray's
content because i just want to be angry
yeah i don't wanna
i don't wanna watch anything good
anymore actually yeah it kind of throw i
didn't know what it was about at first
and all my friends were talking about it
so i was like okay i gotta check this
out and i started watching it and it's
korean the show's korean so they dubbed
it all over in english yeah
like it's dubbed yep but like the voice
acting is [ __ ] horrible yeah netflix
does not do good voice acting
like i don't understand i wish i spoke
korean so i could actually watch the
original because i'm sure the acting is
incredible like visually it's incredible
you can tell they're acting really well
yeah the voice the voices are just so
like lame and lacking energy and emotion
it totally throws you off and the show
is that good where it still
like because they're uh what's the word
i'm looking for here like brain farted
[ __ ] despite of that in spite of that
in spite of that i don't know uh it's
still really [ __ ] good you should
check it out yeah i mean korean
cinematography and korean filmmaking in
general is is super powerful um i'm
trying to remember this horror movie
from like 10 years ago i always bring
this up as an example it's
ah it was like really popular i wish i
could remember the title it
it uh yeah cinematography on that or the
filmmaking that movie was
mind-blowing so
yeah even with that show dark i'm pretty
sure netflix did the
voice overs for that and it's you know
the power rangers had better vocal dubs
than that it's it's
you know i i don't understand and they
it's almost like when they go to cast
they look at the character and they're
like who is the opposite of this person
is this a
strong intimidating character
cool let's hire someone with negative
testosterone and some of the voices are
like so annoying and it just makes the
character kind of unlikable
yeah i wish i could see the original
because i know this character is
probably dope i'm just imagining someone
who did the voiceover work for one of
these characters listening to the show
being like okay ow
i mean i'm sorry if you did but it's
probably not your fault yeah
like damn i don't know whose fault it is
but and it's that's not an easy thing to
do obviously to match the energy of
something that's happening on screen in
front of you yeah you could probably you
know
actually if anything netflix is probably
like we don't want good voice acting
um
we want bad voice acting because that's
how we keep people talking about netflix
did you see the numbers i just read some
tweet
the numbers that netflix pulled in
no i just mean in general i mean
probably for that show too but just in
general yeah i like their top 10 shows
there was some slide that leaked from
one of their decks didn't somebody send
us out in talking points or something
maybe
or did i just see it on twitter randomly
you probably just saw it on twitter
it was uh the top show was um
uh
the new what's the british show i think
it's new newish maybe
um not downton abbey great british bake
off
yeah that one that's the top show
um
going down on abby is that the one
there it is right here 82 82 million
accounts
damn watch that show what's the show
called again bridgeton oh going oh so
it's not going down on abby
not going down on abby that's on a
different website got it bridgerton
season one what is that about a rural
pub
is that a british show even
richardson it just sounds british it
definitely sounds british
yeah like
two bridge builders
living in like the northern uk
and they discover a drag club and they
end up liking it or something i don't
know
go to the slide with the accounts so
that's
82 million
accounts watch that so that's like
i mean how many people per account do
you think on average there is probably
two at least
yeah
and that's [ __ ] insane um i was just
trying
season one 67 million that's all because
of that dude's dick
on tick tock tick tock really is the way
man
yeah that's crazy 67 million people saw
that dude's penis
no more than that probably 100 million
people saw that dude's dick
damn he's got a viral dick
and it wasn't even that good okay
tell us more man was harry's better but
not even that good
what hairstyles is better it was harry's
better when he [ __ ] you
that's uncomfortable
still number seven tiger king 64 million
yeah and they're making another one to
hear that yeah say say what you want
say what you want people loved it you
know don't make another one
yeah stop doing that just leave it i
agree with that how was stranger things
number five man
especially season three who cared oh my
favorite though on the right side top
ten films army of the dead number nine
wait is that that that one that zack
snyder one yep oh my god yeah
oh jesus i've actually
you know this is not really my own
theory but
it kind of is i basically concluded to
myself that
good
isn't good you either want to be
really
you either want to be bad or really
great but you don't want to be just good
because bad and i'm specifically talking
about in entertainment
if you're bad
people love watching
your
continual
dumpster fire you'll always sell tickets
because people want to watch you melt
down
and then if you're like exceptional
people want to see you be that but
you're just good
yeah no one yeah no one [ __ ] cares
yeah you're not signing multi-picture
deals from being good no
you either by being horrible yeah
you either got to be great and that's
not that's not a jab at addison this is
just sort of a
you know
a thing of the
you know
the industry overall as
they either want dumpster fires or
geniuses but nothing in between
so
if you're just a good actor
maybe consider being awful next time you
go off out of acting school yeah for
sure yeah stop doing that [ __ ]
when you do your auditions
do it
[ __ ] god-awful
do it with someone else's voice yeah dub
over your own audition tape just mix it
up do whatever it takes to
completely [ __ ] off the opportunity
you'll be memorable in that way
[ __ ] that'd be that'd be pretty [ __ ]
funny actually you like are going in for
like a frat dude part you know which is
all i ever go out for
and you dress like you're in bridgeton
or something
it's like tweet suit
just go the complete wrong part
you do the whole thing in a british
accent
they're like what the [ __ ]
yeah go in there in um
yeah
uh civil war
reenactment clothing
uh
you know
do the whole thing like you were ulysses
s grant here's the thing though you
can't go in anywhere anymore they're all
self tapes even better man exactly so
you could really do some crazy [ __ ] like
you could deep fry the video oh yeah
like just turn the saturation saturation
up to five times you just say saturation
literally unplug your computer and go
jump in a river dude your career is over
he just said saturation
on a podcast as long as harry styles
gonna think of me if i [ __ ] up a word
like that when i'm meeting him
oh my god guys you heard it here first
cody said saturation
i'm so embarrassed
[Laughter]
anyway you were saying yeah turning up
the situation oh bro no
when you go out to audition you should
just do a totally different script and
just like when your agents are like what
the [ __ ] i actually just did yeah
this was a different audition tape i
just thought the script was better so i
did it for this one too
[Laughter]
yeah i did this one around 2 p.m what
time is it now 4 p.m yeah the
yeah this this one didn't go so well so
i'm going to try it with you guys and i
think i'll be able to nail it this time
yeah nah i mean i think
what else could you just be [ __ ]
terrible at
i mean i i guess i'm targeting
entertainment i can't speak for anything
else but you could kind of do the same
thing that we were talking about with
the harry styles meet and greet like you
could just be really mean
yeah
like what's up [ __ ] um cody co five
nine
which is tall enough don't [ __ ] with me
and i'm reading for the part of i don't
know i don't know i don't remember the
[ __ ] name all right let's go
halfway through the like god this
writing sucks yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you get into character and then break to
be like whoever wrote this [ __ ] blood
gotta yeah them a little bit so it's
like you know it's like class it's like
the game you know yeah
yeah throwing some god who wrote this
anyways uh yeah i'll have the sandwich
sandwich
who orders a sandwich like that
was a [ __ ] sandwich at 6 pm it's not
like realistic at all
you know if i could just add live here
this is probably how i would have did it
and then you you remix it and then
you're like anyway yeah so i'll do it
your way though cause whatever it's your
script uh can i order a sandwich because
i'm an idiot ordering a sandwich at 6
p.m
if there's ever been any advice to take
away from this podcast it's be awful or
be great
yeah
[Laughter]
no vice versa be great or be awful don't
be between